it's late afternoon was hardly any
protesters left security services are
clearing them out there's tear gas than
the whistle of bullets
[Music]
across the street panic a woman has been
hit
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
people rush to pick her up amongst them
her husband she's badly injured she's
propped up on a motorbike and they whisk
her away the other protesters start were
treating the man steps in front of the
camera
she's dead they killed her they killed
as she's dead he shouts a few streets
away they fight to keep the lady alive
outside the emergency room
medics cleaned Ana husbands blood-soaked
body seeing if he is injured he bets a
bet
raus ayo was just 27 years old they say
she wasn't protesting she was just on
the street sky produce it Gustavo ala
man was there a sudden use of live
rounds shocked every now since last
bombs and gas canisters I found our
bomber like like like a series of it and
then a different sound
[Music]
what like a twister and I looked at the
archives our motorbike guys and I say
those are gunshots that they were saying
that and they do like this like we have
to go we have to go the volunteer medics
on these streets are constantly rescuing
people hit by tear gas canisters and
shotgun pellets but live rounds change
everything for everyone there's a second
time in a couple of years that this
street has been the scene of what many
here consider a murder by the security
forces I think it goes to the point in
the message that the regime is making is
that if you go to the streets as a very
good chance that you could be killed
Maduro has appeared with the army to
show that they're very much in control
it's the message they're sending to this
demonstration we are in control of the
country and we're going to stay it's
getting increasingly dangerous here a
journalist is hit by a blast bomb
colleagues rush forward to help he's
been cut by the shrapnel his gas mask
starts filling with blood since the
failed coup the confrontation between
stone-throwing protesters and the
National Guard has turned more violent
it's all about controlling the street
and right now it's the security forces
still Ramzi Sky News Caracas